talk TV
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan uncensored and this
is the interview the entire world has
been talking about Cristiano Ronaldo one
on one
[Music]
from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored welcome to a special edition
of Piers Morgan on censored Cristiano
Ronaldo is a football Mega star in my
opinion the greatest player to ever
grace the game he's also one of the most
famous people on the planet
he saw the toughest year of his life on
and off the pitch facing personal
tragedy and the barrage of criticism
from fans pundits even his own coaches
everyone else has had their say now it's
his turn and Cristiano is most
definitely uncensored
Tiano let me start just by asking you
why are you doing this interview with me
because I think it's the time
to say something
um
and because I like you as simple as that
I don't say that in public
well I like you too and I appreciate it
because I think that you've had to
sustain a lot of criticism this year in
particular probably more than any stage
in your career and I think it's time to
set the record straight and to clear up
a few things not least I suspect for the
fans of Manchester United you must be
wondering what the hell's been going on
oh as I as I say many many times the
fans they always I'm always gonna
say good about them they are
the most important things in football
you play for them they're always in my
side
I feel that every time when I go when I
walk in the streets the fans coming to
me and they appreciate what I did what I
do for football and for me it's the most
important in football the fans for me is
everything
I want to take you back to last year
last summer
your Juventus
and there's massive speculation about
where you're going to go
and the big rumor is that you're going
to go to Manchester City so first of all
how close was that to happening
well honestly
um
it was close
it was close is something that they
spoke a lot
and what the others say
two weeks ago I guess that they try
they try hard to have me
but as you know as my history in
Manchester United your heart you're
feeling the way the history that you did
before
make the difference and of course as
well said Alex Ferguson
so I was I was surprised in the same way
but it was conscious decision uh because
the heart speaks speaking loud in that
moment you were Manchester United Legend
So when you say your heart LED you it's
because of that the history you have
with the club and the relationship you
maintained with Sir Alex with the fans
I think it was it was the key it was the
the difference in that moment but I
cannot be loyal if I would I wouldn't
say that Manchester City wasn't close
but
I think I I did
conscious decision
um
I don't regret
at some point
and as you mentioned before Sarah Alex
Ferguson was was the key and just wait
did you speak to him before you yes I
did yes I did I spoke I spoke with them
with him and
um well this idea to try and persuade
you he said to me that uh
um
it's it's impossible for you to come to
Manchester City and I say okay boss
so I took the decisions and I repeat
with very I was with conscience that
it was a
a good decision
you came back and it couldn't have
started better you played it Old
Trafford yeah you won 4-1 against
Newcastle you scored twice
Alex Sir Alex was there loving it
obviously the return of the prodigal son
your mother was there the return of her
own son uh your mother was crying
obviously obviously yes but what a
comeback uh how did that feel that day
when when you came off the pitch well
that feeling was amazing but not only
the day of the game I I felt before the
week before that everything changed the
world speak about me Cristiano back home
back where they belong so it was a
special special moments to be back to
Manchester United to perform for
uh our fans and of course to score two
goals was the best welcome that I
received in Old Trafford it was Memorial
day and uh unbelievable day too the Viva
Ronaldo charm went up yes we were
Ronaldo you like hearing be back of
course I did yeah as I told you before
the fans for me they are everything
two things happened I think within 24
hours of you re-signing for United one
you broke the all-time record for shirt
sales in 24 hours you actually beat a
guy called Messi PSG you must have been
happy about that of course I do
as you know I'm
I'm I don't follow the records the
records follow me so it's good another
one in my in my book and the other one
was the Manchester United tweet
announcing that you were rejoining the
club was the most
tweeted or most liked tweet I think in
Twitter history
it's good as I told you before it was a
good moment nobody expect
because things
change around in my opinion in 72 hours
which is
you plan or they spoke not only
Manchester City but other clubs too
spoke about your name that you will
change Juventus for another club
but Manchester United wasn't there
wasn't in that part of that teams but
surprise everybody even me to be honest
after a few weeks
things weren't going well at Manchester
United the club just wasn't firing and
in the end Ole gun a solska the manager
got sacked and that's within like two
months of you coming back what were you
feeling about what was going on at
United and what did you feel generally
about the club itself and the state that
the club was in compared to when you'd
been there before
because to be honest when I I signed for
Manchester United I thought everything
was changed because it's 13 years that I
change
I was in Real Madrid nine years and
three in Juventus and when I arrived I
thought everything will be different you
know the technology the infrastructures
and everything but I was surprised
in a bad way let's say in that way
because I saw everything was the same
and Manchester it wasn't it wasn't in
that moment that as you mentioned that
Ollie was suck Michael Carrick he
assumed the the job for to to games
Villarreal and Chelsea away
and everything was was so fast but
surprised me a lot instability in the
club
um everything was kind of the same that
I that I hadn't moved on no they they
stopped on on a clock in my opinion
which is something that that surprised
me I didn't expect
and
um
slowly and slowly they start to change
even even the the windows the new
players and what stuff what stuff for me
because I didn't expect that and uh
because when you were there before
if Manchester United wanted a player
under Sir Alex Ferguson they normally
got their man right now it's a very
different environment after many years
of failure since our Alex retired
the United weren't getting the top
players anymore
so were you surprised by that Dynamic
changing as well because you would have
been used before to them if they wanted
top players they got them I was
surprised I thought when I signed that
they sign in that year essential and
Varan plus me that things will be
in the way that Manchester should be
as you mentioned well Sir Alex Ferguson
left a big gap in the club not only Sir
Alex Ferguson but one person that I
thought make the difference David Gill
the president a very very good man
and the structure around cerallex
fragrance was very important too
I knew it that Manchester United wasn't
the same
but I don't
see that it was so big up so big things
that
go through by the last 10 years
and it was the thing that surprised me
more to be honest with little things
like even the swimming pool the players
use the saunas all these facilities
nothing had changed since you'd left in
2009 nothing changed surprisingly not
only the pool the jacuzzi even the gym
even some points of Technology the
kitchen
the chefs which is I appreciate lovely
lovely persons they stop in a in a time
which is
it surprised me a lot I thought I will
see different things different as I
mentioned before technology
infrastructure
but unfortunately we see many
things that I'm used to seeing when I
was
20 21 23 so surprised me a lot
you'd also of course as you said you've
been at Real Madrid and Juventus where
you saw them moving all the time to
progress with technology the latest
thing to improve performance levels so
you were able to compare what you'd
experienced there with what was not
happening at United
in United they the progress was zero in
my opinion
to compare with Real Madrid and even
Juventus that
they follow
the recent world so the the technology
especially the terms of of training
nutrition and conditions of uh it
properly and to recover better than
before
surprised me Manchester right now to
compare with that club I think it's it's
behind in my opinion which is something
that surprised me a club
with this Dimension
um should be in the top of the tree in
my opinion and
they are not Unfortunately
they are not in that level but I hope
the next years they can reach to be in a
top level
up next Ronaldo scathing verdict almost
gone wrong at Manchester United
[Music]
when you look at I mean United have had
some of the best managers in the world
follows Sir Alex Ferguson and they've
all been relative failures compared to
other stages of their careers do you
think that partly that's down to the the
structural element of this that just
isn't the support that top managers need
I don't know what's going on but since
since the Sarah Lex Ferguson left I saw
not evolution in the club the progress
was Zero
for example you have a interesting point
that how the club as Manchester United
after suck
um
Ali
they buy they bring sport directive
Ralph regnick which is something that
nobody understands this guy is not even
a coach
a bigger club like Manchester United
bring sport directive surprise not only
me but all the worlds you know well it
was a ridiculous decision wasn't it of
course in my opinion it's you have to be
honest if you're not if you're not even
a coach how are you gonna be the boss of
Manchester United it's something that I
should say that Manchester is not
followed not the right way
to reach successful like other teams
like for example Liverpool or Manchester
City Chelsea
they are one step behind or two because
of this kind of mistakes in my opinion
that they should improve and change
probably the
the stuff or or the people uh the
directives or
presidents I don't know who is the
was the problem there but since the show
a lack of ambition to you when they
replace oligonna solskar who a lot of
fans liked but he obviously wasn't
delivering the big titles that United
wanted and were used to but to a point
someone like Ralph running I mean I'd
never heard of him
and I'm thinking about it and I'm
thinking if as you heard of him no of
course not you've never heard of this
guy nobody and the people who I speak
nobody knew it it was him suddenly he's
did you call him the boss
of course I I respect we have to call
because he assumed the job
uh regardless the all the coaches that I
had in my career
I call them boss because if they assume
the the job you have to call in that way
then in the end deep deep inside me I I
never saw him as a boss because I saw
some points that
I never agreed and you stopping the time
as well because if you're not
being a coach the the last the next five
years you're gonna you know you're gonna
lost the identity of to be a coach so
surprised me a lot but in the same way
don't surprise me a lot because if you
see the structures you skip they keep in
the same so the coaches didn't surprise
me but was a tough moment what was
extraordinary was very quickly after
running took over
started briefing journalists that you
weren't pressing enough
and that maybe it would be a good idea
if you moved on from the club and I'm
like who is this guy and why is he
saying this to the man who's scoring the
goals
to be honest basically something that
they
I don't understand it's the new coaches
that coming around they think they find
the last Coca-Cola in the desert which
is that I don't understand the football
Dairy invents many many years so but I
respect any courts have a different
approach different opinions different
mentality but kind of some points that
you are you not agree so I'm always like
that in my life I'm always been besides
the best coaches in the world zidane and
shalotti Maureen and Fernando Santos
allegri
so I had kind of some experience because
I learned from them and when you see
some coaches that they're coming that
they want the revolution the football
are not a Greek I I have my opinion they
agree on they don't they disagree but
it's part of the the business because
I'm in the end of the day I'm in a club
to win and with my experience I want to
help like always and I some coaches they
don't accept
and you know it's part of the job
did he know what he was doing running or
not
at a club like United
no they don't
um
they knew with the club very well
but they don't know the main of the
dimension of the club inside the history
of the club
which is for me surprised me even more
which is when you the suck all this so
scary you should bring a top manager not
sport directive did you think he was
right to get rid of solska or would you
have kept him up
well it's not well I love salskayer I
think it was a top person because what I
what I keep inside my heart it's the
heart of the persons and only for me is
a top person coach of course
it wasn't it didn't it didn't look for
what he what he wants his Hearts his
Hearts to assume after Sir Alex Ferguson
but I think he did a good job for for
sure you need much more time but I'm
never doubts that you're going to be a
good a good coach in the future but it
was a good experience I was I was so
pleased to work with him even a short
period
what about the younger players and and
specifically their mentality because it
seemed to me just from what I was
reading when you were originally at
Manchester United as a young 18 year old
that you had huge respect for the older
players
the Kings and these guys in the dressing
room and you would soak up
their experience their wisdom and so on
did you get that same
respect do you think from the younger
players I don't mean that they don't
respect the experienced players or the
oldest players I don't I don't I don't
think that word it's the the best one
but they live in a different era
um I can't see my kid they have 12 years
old the mentality are not the same they
are not suffered that what's the
difference the anger
I think the younger I think that they
have the things more easily everything
it's easily they don't suffer and I
think it's they don't care I don't mean
only I feel in Manchester United with
all the teams all
all leagues in the world the the
youngest now they are not the same of my
generation but we cannot play blame them
because
is part of the life you know the new
generation and um the the new
technologies that avoid
the distract them for another thing so
but they are not the same they are they
listen but this is why we have two years
you listen from one side and they go
away from Another Side so
don't surprise me but in the same way
it's a little bit shame because if they
have the best examples in front of your
eyes and if they don't at least copy
what you did for me it's kind of it's
kind of weird because I remember when I
was 18 19 20s I'm always looked to see
the best players when Mr Roy Ferdinand
roykin
and that gigs this is why you have the
successful that I have on longevity
because I take care of my body my
mentality my head
because I see these guys and I learn
from them
when you try and give advice to these
younger players what do you say to them
what do you what do you try and guide
them to be like
I think the best advice I'm not the kind
of guys to like to give advice is I
prefer to build as example yeah because
I'm I'm an example
I'm there every morning I do the same
stuff I'm probably the first ones to
arrive and the last one to to go out
I think
the the details speak for itself so
because as I told you before they're
less than one thing and in two minutes
they already forgot and do it whatever
they think it's it's it's better this is
why I say
I like to lead by example and someone's
they follow me not much
but uh see I find that I just find that
incredible
that if I was a young footballer and I
had Cristiano Ronaldo at my club that I
wouldn't want to spend every second
watching him listening to him observing
the way you go about your business and
yet from what you're saying clearly
that's not they're not interested they
don't care
someone's yes but most of them know but
for me it's not surprise me not
surprising because they're not gonna
have longevity careers in my opinion
it's impossible it's impossible
to see for example my Generations you
see many players they they reach 36 37
38 in high level I think this generation
you're gonna count by your hands on many
gonna reach in that level because
this years of preparation it's helps a
lot who were the players in the world
that you most admire for their mental
strength their attitude
it's it's difficult question because I'm
I'm always can say what I see from my
highs for example if you tell me
what I see for example in Manchester
United I can mention probably download
his example is young but he's very
very professional and I'm not doubt that
they're gonna reach you're gonna have
longevity in football because he's he's
young he's smart intelligent and he's
very professional you have a few ones
more but like him it's it's difficult to
see probably Martinez
um casimiro's start is
um
but I will say dalot
tell me
Italians are from the toughest moment of
his life
[Music]
so the Runnings come then it's your
second manager it's not working the
results aren't great you're still
scoring goals regularly for Manchester
United you're about the only one who is
but then you get hit by an awful
episode in your life probably the worst
time of your life
where your partner Georgina she's
pregnant with twins and is actually
giving birth to these two babies
and your baby son doesn't survive
and I don't think I can imagine I have
four kids you have a lot of children
you know you can't imagine a worse thing
to happen than to go a full term of a
pregnancy particularly for the poor
mother in that case but also for you
what was that like for you that that
time in your life is probably the worst
moment that I passed through my life
since my my father died you know when
you have a kid that you expect that
everything will be normal and you have
that uh problem it's it's hard you know
as human being that I am in Georgina why
we had quite difficult moments because
we don't understand why
happened to us
was difficult to be honest was was very
very difficult to to understand what's
going what's going on in that in that
period of our life
as you know the football carry on there
are so fast many competitions the
football don't stop we are many many
competitions
and pass through in that moment was
probably the most difficult moment that
I had in my life me and my my family
especially Geo that was was tough she
said um she was giving an interview
about the new series of her TV show and
she said in an interview a big piece of
my heart shattered and I asked myself
how I could carry on I had the answer
nearer than I thought I looked into the
eyes of my children and there I saw the
only way of doing it being all together
yeah I I I saw too yeah this is why what
we did we I got my my family especially
Geo and um
we had the difficult moments but we say
listen we have more more kids we have
one that born Bella that we have to be
happy to I mean such a difficult
situation again where you're mourning
the terrible loss of your little baby
boy but also celebrating the birthday of
your beautiful daughter I'll try to
explain sometimes to my family and even
my close friends they say I never felt
to be happy and sad in the same moment
yes I never felt it is hard to explain
um it's so difficult so difficult it's
you don't know if you cry or you don't
know if you smile because it's something
that you don't know how to react you
don't know what to do to be honest and
of course I remember very well that
I look like
I don't know the word that to Define
what I felt in that moment but it's it's
crazy feeling it's crazy emotional
but as I told you before I I
have to to hold that we had at least
Bella yes which is the most important
one die and one survive
but it was it's difficult to explain how
did you explain it all to your other
children they must have been so confused
about in the beginning do you arrive in
home and the kids start to say where's
another baby where's another of course
Cristiano I had conversation with him
in the in the day
and because he's 12 years old he knows
he understands everything and I had a
nice conversation with him we cried
together in his bedroom
and he explained and it's kind of
he don't understand he understand but in
the same way it was a little bit
confused the other ones in the beginning
in the table the kids start to say mom
where is the uh the other baby and Geo
in the beginning they start to say
because you know she she had a little
bit barely because they had two it's
hard process
and after one week I say you know let's
let's be frontal let's be honest with
the kids let's let's say that's uh Angel
which is the name they go to the to the
heaven
it's better to say in that way yeah
and uh we start to use that in that uh
in that way and the kids always
understand when we had shots in a table
and they say Daddy I did this for hand
gel and they they pawned out for the for
the sky which is I I say and I and I
like it the most because you know it's
part of the lives and I am not gonna lie
to my kids to say the true which is was
a difficult process but in the same way
I become more more father more friendly
of them they become more
more close to his daddy especially me
with Georgine as well I was going to ask
you that because these things they can
they can't make or break relationships
because the grief can be so intense it
can Drive couples apart or it can bring
them closer
in my case it was more
what's better in that way I become more
friendly
of Geo I was of course friend but I see
more more lovely for her and for my for
my kids and I start to see the life with
a different perspective you understand
which is coming the point of if you're
gonna ask me for sure
the preseason moments for example why I
didn't go to the prison so I'm gonna
come today but it was
just to finish in that that chapter was
the most difficult moment
the last since my dad died it was this
moment that I passed through the last
six months
do you feel your son is is with you in
spirit for sure for sure his ashes is
with me like my daddy they are here in
my house yes yes
is something that it's I want to hold
for the rest of my life I'm not throw to
the to the ocean or to the sea I keep
with me there next to my to my daddy
I've I don't know if you
you check have a small Church down and
you do yes I do like a little chapel yes
chapel and I keep my dad and my son do
you talk to them yes I do
um I I talk with them every time
and that they are in my side they are
you know they help me
to be a better man to be a better person
to be a better father and it's something
that I'm really really proud that the
message that they send me especially my
my son amazing
you had an extraordinary reaction from
football fans obviously from Manchester
United but I think you must have been
just so surprised by the outpouring of
not just support but Liverpool fans sang
on the seventh minute of their next game
You'll Never Walk Alone the cop the
great Infamous enemy of Manchester
United what did you feel when you heard
that I never ever expect that never
I had the opportunity now to to say
all English Community thank you a lot
for that kind of that they had with me
not only Liverpool but all England I
felt I was awesome when you played in on
the seventh minute the whole crowd I
received I received a letter from
the queen family as well really yes I do
which is from the queen itself yeah
family yeah and um
surprised me a lot offering their
condolences yes wow unbelievable this is
why I say I respect a lot the English
Community English people
because they've been very kind with me
and in that difficult moment on my life
was spectacular the way they treat me me
and my family and that difficult moments
I I should say straight to the
commenting thank you to the Old English
community that helped me in that moment
the when the queen sadly died in
September you posted a very nice tribute
to her was part of the reason because of
of what they had I've got in life with
you of course they've been so kind of
with me and um this is why I did what I
did
uh but it was unbelievable moment and
never ever gonna forget that moment
you have a little girl Bella she's six
months old now
must be a great joy I made all that
terrible sadness unbelievable it was
another member in the family they are
the the shine of the house
and we are so proud May Georgina and all
all my kids they are they are very very
proud for them they are they are
spectacular beautiful
girl and we are so happy we are so so
happy we are we are happy Fathers you're
gonna have more
I'm not thinking now to thinking more
kids I think we we done but we never
know the future only Gods know but right
now we all want to to have a break to
enjoy this once because they are little
Bella six and the rest there are five
and Christiano 12. we want to enjoy a
little bit of these ones let's see the
future
it's very difficult to play top level
football at the best of times it's a
hard business and full public glare of
millions of people watching to have to
go back and play after this
must have been incredibly hard for you
even with your mental strength how did
you find that
difficult very difficult to to play
after that but as I always have good
support from my family and Georgina tell
me go go to play go enjoy to do what you
like to do
you're gonna help for you to forgot
forget a little bit the situation
was difficult but in the same point I
think helps helps for you to you know to
don't think much about that even to
training was good but
as you know the
the football going so fast and you know
trainings games uh even the national
team the things going so fast you don't
even have a time to settle and say
what's going on you know
because the things going so fast but
was good help Georgina helped me a lot
to give me that possibility to say she's
a very strong woman yes she's Georgina
yes I mean really strong yes to to just
to be your partner it's probably not an
easy time a lot of the time with all the
attention all the time but to go through
what she's gone through and still you
know be there we help each other but she
struggle when he when she is young which
she now she look at life in a different
with the different eyes even she's young
but she suffer you know she's she born
in Argentina she have his issues with
his family as well
she live alone she have interesting life
and histories as well history and she
helped me a lot she is very mature for
his age we we help each other sometimes
when I'm a little bit down she pushed me
up
and I do it to the other side so we are
a nice couple we help each other so
I'm really pleased that she's in she's
on on my side any any movement on the
The Wedding Bells Cristiano I'm not
thinking now about that but I can see in
the future I think I deserve she deserve
but it's something that come not coming
now in my in my plans but in the future
oh yes yes I won
coming next Wayne Rooney Gary Neville
Ronaldo's got a message for both of you
[Music]
four days after this terrible time in
your life
you need to get a new manager Eric
tenharg did you know much about him a
little bit
um
through
ayax the job that I did for IX
you end the season with 24 goals for
Manchester United including 18 in the
Premier League six in the Champions
League he was second in the Golden Boot
for the English football I mean by any
normal yardstick that's an incredible
performance
and you were still getting criticized it
was almost like well it's got to be your
fault even though you scored all the
goals were you as bemused as I was that
you were becoming the focal point for
the criticism
I think it's if it's easy to point out
when you want to cover other things to
put to point out Cristiano Ronaldo it's
it's it sees everyone now that that
press they wanna
they wanna put me in the first page
because they know they will sell more
than dressing will be different
and I'm used to live like that because
when I was 37
uh I know and I'll learn many things
when you are
in the down of the wave when you are in
the top of the wave it's you don't
realize and you don't see things that
you don't see before which is I
appreciate to have bad moments to see
which people is in your side who
criticize you more because they're
looking for that they don't like to see
successful people the people only try to
bring negativism and I felt the last
four or five months that
not only with for me but even for my
family as well for Georgina especially
around the world the Press criticized me
even more and sometimes I don't I don't
understand
why even
Portuguese press that they criticize
criticize me a lot
I don't understand but I still believe
that
the jealous is part of that they want to
cover many things that
helps
to to shine other things but listen
Pierce I know I'm 25 21 years in the top
of the game so I know how it takes so
for me it's not a problem it's it's hard
when you are a little bit
down
to listen to this criticize hey do you
read it all do you read newspapers do
you read social media a good thing that
I have it's I don't like to read because
I know
90 of the times they lie they are
garbage they press they are garbage not
all of them but most of them
they don't say the true
um and they're like the constant lie and
the constant attack me and my family
they're always negativism against my
family
why I'm gonna read because I know they
try to to to make me feel bad me and my
family which is is something hard to
deal but
in the end of the day I understand
but it's it's really really hard the
problem you have is you're too famous
you are the most followed human being on
Instagram that you have I just checked
495 million followers I have just under
2 million on Instagram eight million on
Twitter so I'm catching you on Twitter
slowly but but for one you're nearly at
half a billion followers on Instagram
that's insane
you're bigger than all the Kardashians
put together it's good it's good I feel
proud for that it means it means a lot
for me because
it means that people like me too I'm
charismatic I think
why I'm the number one sometimes asking
ask that question to myself why me I'm
not another one why do you think it is
to be honest I not just only because I I
play good football because everyone
knows but I think the rest is is
relevant you have to be charismatic
people have to to feel some connection
with you
I think to be good looking helps too I
have the same book yeah I feel the same
way to be honest because I don't know
the real reason but
I think I'm charismatic and I'm
I'm a pettitive fruit I don't know if we
a fruit that people want to bite yeah I
don't know that the how you can say in
English any particular fruit or
let's say it's strawberry
but I don't know the
the reason I mean what's incredible to
me is the the power you have appetite
appetite appetite appetite fruit
appetite fruit I don't know if it makes
sense in English but if you don't make
sense you learn I'll write research
appetite fruit yeah I mean I have a
pinned tweet and it's you telling me I
have good abdominals which is a very
good observation and it's only 10
seconds long it's had 43 million views
this clip so thank you very good 43
million people have heard the guy who
actually has got good abdominals tell me
everybody abdominals but it showed me
that the sheer Firepower you have in
that what in that world and social media
it's just extraordinary
is is what I what I tell you before
um I have
I have good things which is is you you
can sell your own product let's say in
that way but you have to to deal with
many obstacles in your life too do you
care if people
hate you I mean a lot of people love you
but obviously a lot of people don't
you're so big you're going to get both
but you care about the ones who I care
hate Cristiano right now I care the
people who like me I'm not waste time
for the people who don't like magic is
waste of time these people they are they
are not interested in my life I like to
be a surround around the people who love
me I don't I don't waste my time to to
see the criticize of people who is next
to me ex-players for example
uh I mean one of your biggest critics
has been and I'm surprised about this me
too Wayne Rooney for example who you
played with for many years very
successfully and we're good friends with
him and yet all this year three or four
times he's come out and attacked you in
the media because I don't understand you
should ask this question to him but
I don't know
um I don't know why you criticized me so
bad or not because he says jealous of me
says your behavior is unacceptable
United should sell you you know blah
blah blah blah I mean sweet Rooney it's
broken it was one year ago or six months
ago here in my house you pick up his
kids here and invite Christian to go his
house to play football I don't I really
don't understand people like that or if
they want to be in the cover of the of
the paper of the news or the one in your
jobs or whatever
is it jealousy as well perhaps that
you're still playing and still in the
united probably because he finished his
career with 30s so I'm still playing
higher level I'm not gonna say that I'm
looking better than him which is this is
true but
but that is inarguable I mean there's no
contest is is hard to listen that kind
of criticize a negative about
people who we play with you for example
getting Neville as well yes I mean Gary
never you blanked him the other day uh
on the pitch and he looked quite upset
actually
um because he obviously likes being your
friend but he's been pretty critical of
you as well when you haven't can have
his own opinion but they don't really
know what's going on for example inside
the the training ground and Carrington
area or even my life they should listen
not only one point of view they have to
listen my point of view as well because
it's easy to to criticize but if you
don't know the old story it's it's it's
easy you know but it's as I say before
it's it's part are they still friends of
yours or do you have a line where they
are not my friends they are colleagues
we play together they they're not coming
we're not ever dinner together for
example
but as I told you appears before it's
part of my journey they kill they keep
criticize me negativism every time so I
follow I continue my my trip and uh I
have to catch up the people who like me
some of your ex colleagues have been
incredibly supportive
Rio Ferdinand has always got your back
Roy Keane always has your back whatever
happens it's always supported you and
has continued to do so does that mean a
lot to you it means a lot because they I
was in a dressing room with them
they are part of my journey in football
as well as I mentioned many times
rocking for me was my best Capital ever
real ferdinary helped me a lot it was my
neighbor I was his neighbor so very very
good guys not just because they speak
good about me but there there was there
in the dressing room they are football
players they know how players thinking
and the behaves
Etc
and to listen Ace X
colleagues or teammates to criticize you
and they only see one point of view do
you feel a bit but do you feel a bit
betrayed when they do that because you
because you played together it's easy
it's easy to criticize I don't know if
you'd have
a job in television that they must
criticize
to a to be more famous I really don't
understand doesn't they use your name a
bit too I think they take advantage of
that because they are not stupid and I
really understand and I have to carry on
with my life with criticize criticize or
or
when the people speak good about you but
it's hard when you see people who was in
a dressing room with you criticizing
that way it must hurt it's not good yes
I do but but hardly I I'm not gonna be
more slim I'm not gonna sleep bad
because of the criticize but it's not
good to listen that disappointing
a little bit yes disappointing
an excellent sensored expect fireworks
to the explosive second half of my 90
minutes with Ronaldo
your baby daughter's in hospital and the
president of uh
um Manchester United didn't believe the
empathy don't exist the glazes had done
they don't care about about the club
what would your message be to Manchester
United fans the fans for me will be
always in my heart he was deliberately
provoking you I didn't felt that he had
a respect for me Cristiano Ronaldo's 12
rules to life why not imagine the rest
of the rats they're gonna criticize you
too
I'm just trying to work out how Wayne
Rooney could hate you even more they
only speak about the black Chip which is
his name it's trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around
the club yes I feel betrayed if you
don't have respect for me I'm never
gonna have respect for you you think
England have a have a chance have a
chance beside Portugal in my opinion
that's it you retire right yeah I
retired 100
[Music]
.
you won't want to miss it whatever
you're up to keep it uncensored
thank you
[Music]
this is Piers Morgan on Saturday coming
up Revelation from Ronaldo football's
biggest superstar gives his blistering
verdict on life of Manchester United
[Music]
organ uncensored
welcome to the special edition of Piers
Morgan on sensitive the next hour
Cristiano Ronaldo turns up the heat his
sensationally reveals he has no respect
for his current manager he calls out
Manchester United's owners the glazes he
talks candidly about his future at Old
Trafford and the World Cup in Qatar he
even reveals his retirement plans and
what do you think sibling or Messi but I
begin with a very personal question
yeah do you have more pounds in the bank
or more Instagram followers
it's a good question probably similar I
don't know
probably similar uh I'm just trying to
work out how Wayne Rooney could hate you
even more and probably that's the answer
well not only him imagine the rest of
the rats they're gonna criticize you too
but it's good it's good to be still
number one if you you see the make
something that make me happy too if you
see Forbes Magazine every year I'm in
the top of the list so it's not by
coincidence too but knowing you I don't
it's not the money so much it's just you
want to be at the top right I mean
that's what I think what drives you
someone said to me what drives Cristiano
Ronaldo I don't think it's money I think
it's being the best
beating people it's a competitive streak
the the records the adrenaline but
Pierce let's let's let's be uh honest
the last years the football change
I see football now as a business to be
honest
sometimes the Georgian have expression
that I don't understand they treat you
they treat you players like a piece of
meat and say yes you say everything is
true when they want you when they they
they they count with you they give you
everything when they don't they try to
to make a hard life to you
I see football piece the last years as a
business I saw many many things that I'm
disappointing the passion for the game
is still intact but in the same way I
say I saw other things as well
which is
surprised me but in the same way
it's part of the business because
if you see the world how it is in the
moment it's it's all business everyone
take on itself everyone they are more
individual well you become a commodity
where if you can sell record number of
shirts in 24 hours great right but if
suddenly the team isn't performing well
they need someone to blame it looks to
me like at Manchester United the default
position is it's got to be Cristiano's
fault exactly it's always always my
fault the problem is always me I look
like I'm the black sheep which is I
don't like if you do it good or if you
do bad they all is going to find some
some criticize even in the national team
the last three months as I told you
before the criticize was so bad I mean
not only in football way but
professional
and family way as well which surprised
me a lot
looked like I was a bad guy which is not
true people have to listen
from my mouth the real the facts as well
this is why I give this interview
because I thought I I think it's the the
right time to speak out of my my mind
which is what they say the last four or
five months is completely garbage I'm
not gonna say 100 but 99 it was garbage
people say false things are alive things
which things have annoyed you the most
family issues
um well I want to talk about one in
particular on that which is when you
were late back for the pre-season
training a lot of speculation because
you'd said several weeks before that you
wanted to play Champions League football
and that you were maybe looking for
another option because it didn't look
like United would get to play Let's make
my points for example the preseason
moment and after you mentioned
new clubs or interesting for example the
preseason I had a very very bad
which is I don't say nobody the people
who surround me they saw friends and
even my mom I had some problems in
vacation that my young daughter they
have a little problem they have brown
kids which is system conscious
bronchitis yes yes your little baby yes
I was in Mallorca and holidays and
sister one week in hospital
which is was
you know you don't enjoy a lot and after
what had happened so well exactly and
the people make make up histories that
they say that I don't want to go travel
because they people have to understand
that I'm a human being I'm always going
to be in my side of my family
I'm not negotiate nothing behind that
you understand
and I even have the the lectures of from
the hospital the the feedback of the
health of Bella which is I'm not sure
nobody nobody asked me I have I keep for
me people forget that I'm human human
being that I passed through a difficult
moments
well you must have been worried sick I
mean you I was very worried I was very
baby son and now your baby daughter's in
hospital exactly and you must have been
absolutely directive of
and the president of Manchester United
and then
kind of that didn't believe
that something going wrong which is make
me feel bad really yes I am yes I didn't
believe you
they believe you but in the same way
they are there and never this ever gonna
change
the health of my family
for the football never
now or 10 years
behind or forwards and it's something
that really hurt me because they doubt
of my words that I struggle especially
Bell and Jill we had one week in
hospital because the Bell have a big
problem
and I didn't go to the preseason because
of that because I didn't I didn't
was allowed to left my family if
something happened
to do the Precision because I think it
wasn't not fair to left my family for a
preseason this is why I didn't go
I mean that would if my employer didn't
believe a story like that that would
I would be so angry
because everyone I'm not mentioned only
in that in that
Manchester way but in the world
especially in the football world
they are very very very individual
everyone everyone everyone on look for
on selves or himself
they don't care about
your moments your struggle moments your
issues family problems
they want you they want you doesn't
matter
your family problems I don't mean
Manchester but in a general
as I told you before the football goes
so fast you have many competitions many
games pre-season woke up now listen we
have last you have one game after three
four days you have to be in the national
team preparation for the World Cup it's
hard sometimes you have to sell
everything and you know
be with your family
take the best decisions and
in this summer I didn't feel comfortable
I feel uncomfortable the way they treat
me especially the the Press they doubt
about me the professional that I am
it's impossible to be 21 in the top of
the game if you're not professional they
doubt about me which has made me feel
very very very sad because in my life
I'm always one of the best professionals
this is why I'm still playing that level
you play in a pre-season friendly and
you leave the ground early with several
other players and there's another huge
fuss about this
what was the truth about that had you
got permission to go do you wish you
hadn't left early now Ken Hogg wasn't
happy it was reported what's the truth
because um I'll I will be honest with
you
um
is something that I regret to left from
the stadium probably or maybe no I don't
know it's difficult to
tell you 100 percent
if I'm
but let's say I regret
but in the same way I felt provoked by
the coach I'm not allowed for me
a coach to put me in three minutes in
the game Sorry I'm not that kind of
player I know what I can give to the
teams you're talking about the Tottenham
thing the Tottenham yeah I'm talking
about in pre-season it was a friendly
where you left the ground with a several
of me and eight players right so that
they mentioned only my name yeah which
is his
everyone do that
I don't understand why they mentioned
only about about Harry Vala kind of play
a game
last year many players do the same in
that game eight players do it the same
so but they only speak about the black
Chip which is me which is I completely
understand okay it's done I apologize to
the coach and for me
the chapter was was closed
coming next Ronaldo is being forced out
of Manchester United
[Music]
it seemed to me that right from the
start ten Hogg wanted to show you who
the boss was
that he dropped you he benched you
mucked you around
he talked about you in the Press
were you getting that feeling I mean did
you feel that the feeling he always
mentioned to me that I did indeed the
pre-season so I should wait for my
opportunity I really understand I should
well okay I understand
but I'm not gonna give you
points but
you don't do it the same sediment from
to every players I'm not going to
mention players but they don't do it the
same way
second I understand that
becoming a new job Manchester was so bad
the last five years that it should make
they should clean the house let's say in
that way
but the way they approach the way the
Press make this so big it's because
probably the
the communication wasn't the best uh but
I I really understand in the beginning
because I didn't do the pre-season I
don't start to play but going more
farther than that further than that
other things happen that people they
don't know
and I'm not I'm not uh hiding that the
empathy with the coach is not good I'm
I'm honest you don't have a good
relationship with him I'm not mean good
relationship the empathy is not it's not
good let's say you think he respects you
I think you don't you don't respect the
way I should deserve
but
it is what it is this is why probably
the the game against Tottenham well I've
only come to these two games so against
Manchester City where United got
destroyed
he didn't bring you on
you brought another Strikers but didn't
bring you on and
I felt insulted on your behalf I was
like surely against Manchester City if
you're losing this badly and you've got
the greatest player of all time sitting
there you at least give him some time
don't you but he didn't and he said
afterwards the reason was he had too
much respect for he wanted to respect
you when you heard him say that what did
you think
excuses
I say as excuses
I sell many things that
I don't wanna I don't want to criticize
him it can it can have different opinion
than me that they choose the players
that I think it's better for the team I
respect that but the excuses all the
time you know excuses have short legs
you cannot excuse all the time which is
things that don't make sense okay you
don't put me against Manchester City
because of respect of your career and
you want to put me three minutes against
well that's the thing so then you then
play top that doesn't make sense and
then he wants to bring you on with three
minutes to go which is the complete
opposite to what he said the situation
was with City I think it did it did it
did purpose because for example in the
national team the other clubs if the
coach want to put me five minutes if
someone injured or if they really need
me I will help but in that way I felt
provoked not only because of that game
but before something he was deliberately
provoking him nice for everyone everyone
know that disrespecting you think
exactly this is why I say I don't have
respect for he him because they don't
show me respect for me this is why
we we are we are in that situation I
have to be I have to be honest that the
things done going well because of that
because the empathy don't exists and it
keeps it keeps say things for the Press
but the Press
say what they think it's it's it's good
to protect probably him and Manchester
United but as I know as I understand
many things that is signed three years
contract with Manchester United probably
I'm not going to be too much longer in
Manchester United apart when I'm
finished my contract I really understand
but I like guys that
they don't like they speak honest they
beat frotel frontal and I'm not going to
negotiate my morals my morals always
will be intact and what what's going in
my in my in my things the last two
months was
um not respect in many ways
which is it I can regret for example
against Tottenham to left the stadium
before uh the Finish Well there's a
video clip which appears to show ten
Hart telling you to get ready to come on
and you gesticulate back to him I'm not
going to do that and as a result you get
suspended for the next couple of games
and he goes public and says this because
he refused to come on and you did then
issue a statement of some regret saying
you know you're a professional and
you've never been suspended before I
don't think now entire career I mean
when you look back at that I guess my
question would be you've always been
very acutely aware of Your Role Model
status around the world
do you wish with hindsight you hadn't
done that and handled it I regret to
left the stadium yeah but I was as I
told appears before I didn't felt that
he had respect for me to put me on three
minutes after the issues that we had
before
um
I was very very very very disappointing
for
the communicate of Manchester United to
be honest I never had a problem with any
club with any coach
and they suspending three days which is
I felt a lot and it was
and and level of sport clubs I felt a
lot and it was a shame is it humiliating
I think so yes I have to to say the
truth what I felt I remember I arrived I
I arrived
well I don't want to say I don't want to
say details what they pretend to do it
but I'm not going to say that but I
remember arriving home and Christiana
see me that did you not go to the game
and say no because
the club punished me with three days and
he did like
oh they're gonna punish you if you are
the best player in the world and uh
you're not gonna play say no I'm not
gonna play because I I'm not being I'm
behave and you look at me like my dad
did not behave what
in one way I was
good because I was like more relaxed but
in the same way I feel very disappointed
because
okay I regret I apologize I'm not
perfect I commit a mistake but to
suspend me in three games three days
for that I think it's too much and they
they make fire for the Press which is
really disappointment and that seems to
have been the pattern of the way ten
Harkers wanted to treat you since he
became manager just constant
attempt to disrespect you I guess
many many points happen
I think in some certain points I think
was strategy
from the club for me to react like that
because they wanted you to leave
probably yes they're trying to force you
out yes not only the coach but the other
two or three guys there around
the club
at the senior executive level yes that I
felt betrayed
and you think they're trying to get rid
of you
honestly I shouldn't say that I don't
know but listen I I don't care I'm
always people should listen the truth
yes I feel betrayed and I felt that some
people that don't want me here not only
this year but last year too
but they didn't want you to go there at
all no really yes
the owners of the club they listen
they've done the glazes the glazes had
done they don't care about about the
club I mean
professional uh
sport
as you know this Manchester is a
marketing Club they will get
his money from the marketing
the sports
it's that that don't really care in my
opinion you ever talk to them the glazes
never never not since you've gone back
no they give all the power to the
president the sport directive
a lot of Manchester United fans
are very negative about the glazes they
think they're taking all the money out
and are spending enough on players on
the infrastructure issues he talked
about do you think the fans are right
the fans are out they're always right I
think the fans should know the true
should know that
the place we want the best for the club
I want the best of the club this is why
you're coming to Manchester United this
is why I love this club
but you have some
things inside the club which is don't
help
to Manchester reach the top level as
City Liverpool and even now Arsenal for
example
which is complicated it's difficult
um
it's hard in my opinion it will be hard
for Manchester to be in the top of the
game
the next two three years the Glazer
stays on it I'm not mean the glazes but
the structure this structure
um
as
as Picasso say you have to destroy it to
rebuild and if they can start from me
I'm
for me it's not a problem I'm always one
gonna say I love Manchester United I
love defense they're always on my side
but if they want to do it different era
different generation they have to change
many many things
when you walked away at Spurs and didn't
go on Gary Neville said your behavior
was unacceptable called for you to be
punished he said he knows what he's
doing he's experienced and players of
that power have a real negative impact
when they do it the influence they have
on other players is really negative
and it's after that you
gave them the old blank treatment which
was very funny by the way
um
but for Neville to say that about you
they can't they can't they only they
don't see the big picture
why I react like that what's happened
all the behind the scenes all the behind
the scenes I was
probably not provoke
they will accept to play three minutes
after all situations that going through
the last two months
don't tell me that top players the guys
want everything the key players
will play three minutes come on this is
unacceptable after what
they keep saying before that they
respect me they do this they do that
for me it wasn't not respect this is why
I take this decision I regret I've
I apologize to my teammates for the
situation I did a post
and Instagram I regret to left from the
stadium I regret my teammates they know
what I felt I said to them apologize but
in the same way I'm not regret to take
the decisions to done coming on I'm like
that I will be always like that if you
don't have respect for me I'm not going
to have respect for you and the coach
didn't have respect for me so this is
why
the relationship it's it's in that way
and it keeps saying and oppressed that
he can't with me like me but it's only
for the Press really yes 100
so where are you now in your head with
all this because the World Cup is about
to start you're going to go there with
Portugal and we'll talk about that in a
moment with a very exciting team
actually
um but where are you with the United
they won't be playing again now until
after Christmas that leaves a few days
before the January transfer window do
you think you'll still be a United
player come January 1st it's difficult
to tell her right now because we my
moods is right now
to the World Cup it's probably my last
World Cup of course my fifth World Cup
I don't know what's going to happen uh
after the World Cup but as I told you
before and I will say again
the funds will be always in my heart and
I hope they
've been in my side
even if I back or if I'm not back or if
I stay or whatever
nobody's perfect episodes in the life we
all have uh
is part of
the human beings is part of me to be a
human being and father as well
I always will commit a mistakes
uh but I don't know it's hard to tell
you right now what's going to happen the
World Cup because my focus is only for
the World Cup for the Portugal national
team
coming next for Ronaldo still be Old
Trafford after the World Cup I'll ask
him
[Music]
if you had your time again knowing what
was going to happen
would you sign for Manchester United
again
as I told in the beginning I'm always
took my decisions by
not
emotional moments but maybe this
this decision I took by emotional
I'm not regret
because I took with 100 conscience
but it was more emotional than rational
I don't know if this makes sense
uh but it was good was good because
I was happy
when they left maybe happy
so I tried to give my advices my
experience
to help Manchester United to be where
they deserve to be
um
I don't pretend to be more smart than
the other ones nobody is smarter than me
but I'm not smarter than nobody
when I arrived in Manchester United I
always be
available to help the team to do the
good things to put in the right spot
to compete with the best teams
but it's hard when they they cut your
legs and they don't like you to shine on
they don't listen your advices I think I
I have Awards to advice to the club
because the trophies that I won
individual and Collective I think I can
help a lot but when the infrastructure
is not
good what's amazing is you ended last
season
with hat tricks you're scoring hat
tricks for fun one against Tottenham
you know you were playing great football
but you were starting most games and now
this season you've barely started any
game something happened you know I'd
imagine you're a bit like a racehorse
right if you don't start I didn't indeed
depressed season right right is there is
the excuse right which is the preseason
so you think if you've been able to just
do what you did last season you just got
carried on scoring for sure you think I
I just learned
to score goals maybe I'm not motivated
that I'm supposed to be probably as I
told you before because I'm human being
I feel the things
I'm not perfect
but my motivation is not the same that I
was that I was a few months ago
and I hope to change do you feel like
you need a fresh challenge
I'm not saying if it's fresh fresh
challenge but let's say let's say I'm
not I cannot answer right now because my
focus is for the World Cup
but I don't know maybe it's good for
Manchester and berries and probably is
good for me as well
to have a new chapter probably but I
don't know if if I will be back I will
be the same Cristiano but I hope people
being on my side and let me shine like I
did
all the clubs and all ears what is the
truth about other clubs making offers
for you some people have said there were
no offers at all I happened to know that
there was a gigantic one from Saudi
Arabia for example 350 million euros for
two seasons is that okay yes it's true
that's a staggering sum of money yes
which you turned out in that moment yes
I mean that to me says you're not just
about the money this is what it's what
I'm going to mention now it's they say
many many garbage thing that
if you are Urgent what you're going to
do you go the clubs but George Mendes
for example have more than 100 players
and they go Chelsea they go Arsenal they
always mention Cristiano Ronaldo they
offer Cristiano base let's be honest
who's the most expensive player salary
player that
Premier League have in history
it's me even with 37 years old why
they're gonna even they even offer me
to sporting Annapolis I will be honest
with you you don't I didn't have many
many clubs but I have many many offers
of the other clubs which is I didn't
change because I didn't plan to do it
but I have but what the Press keeping
say and the garbage price say that
nobody want me which is completely wrong
and I was happy here to be honest I was
motivated to do it a great season here
but but they continue to repeat nobody
won Cristiano how how they don't want to
play to last year's got 32 goals
with national team I mean that's the
point I don't get because there are
people out there and you see them you
hear them
and they say well he's not the player he
used to be as if somehow at 37 you're
going to be as good as you were at 21.
anyway everyone change but you are the
greatest 37 year old anyone's ever seen
right and you're still extremely fit so
it just seems to me nothing's changed
from the player I saw banging in hat
tricks last season except that you have
a coach who doesn't want to start you a
few months or what they're going to
change there's nothing
I feel like you can still be a top
player but for me it's it's it's it's
stupid questions when people say ah they
are not the same nobody is the same
day by day we're getting old every one
of us you understand it's normal you
have to adapt and I think nobody in this
game
have this brain that adapts with his age
I'm not I'm not want to be cocky to say
that I'm the same that when I asked 20
of course no but I'm adopt and I be
smart to know my strength what I'm good
to do and I'm still playing high level
and I score goals and I will continue to
score goals if my mind is clear and
happy and if the people surround me
there help me to be successful player
especially the coach president
directives but when you feel that the
energy don't go surround you it's
difficult you to be yourself which is
happening this is what's happened with
me but what they say the last three
months is completely garbage and wrong
they say that I offer me this and that
and many presidents and directives speak
about their reject from it's completely
lie they'll lie because he's is is not
what's happened I had many clubs not
many a few clubs that they want me to
sign and I didn't go because I feel
comfortable here this is the truth how
easy is it to turn down 350 million
pounds to kick a football for two years
in Saudi Arabia it's hard it's hard it's
hard but in the same way I I thought
that I was very happy here that I still
capable to score goals and make people
up is it also that you want to keep
playing at the highest level that you
want to play Champions League Football
you want to keep breaking records is it
again it comes back to my gut feeling
about you that if it was just about
money you would be you'd be in Saudi
Arabia right earning this king's Ransom
but you that's not what motivates you
you want to keep exactly because I
thought I I still believe that I can't
score many many goals and helped the
team because I I still believe that I'm
I'm still good and capable to help
national team even Manchester United but
if you don't feel surrounded that the
energies is in in your side it's
difficult of course the criticized gun
exists all the time I 37 is still not
the same but I want to see if some guy
of my heads maintained the level that I
that I show you're not going to teach me
that nobody gonna teach me that I know
are you as fit as you've ever been do
you think yes yes in this moment I feel
very very good I believe that I'm gonna
do it Amazing World Cup
I'm prepared physically and mentally
but
peace is it it is what it is life is
good I'm good my mental is good I'm
happy to do this entire video I know
they're gonna generate very polemic of
course but Christianity they would
anyway right I mean they've all had
their say and now you're entitled to
have your say and you know better than
anybody because you are Cristiano they
criticize me when I don't speak of
course when I'm gonna speak according to
criticize me even more but it's
something that I can I can deal with
that I know I'm gonna disappointing a
few people maybe I'm gonna make up a few
people but
it is what it is the life is it's
completely
difficult we have obstacles in our lives
and uh
I will keep running to fight against the
people who don't believe me and the life
is a challenge and I wanted people the
people that they are wrong when they say
that if you do leave United and I accept
this is not a done decision either way
but if you do and it seems to me like
that's more likely than not as we sit
here
what would your message be to Manchester
United fans who've had to
read all this stuff all year and
probably have a very mixed idea about
where the truth lies what would you say
to them if you do end up leaving
it's hard it's hard for me to say that I
will not be back to Manchester United
but regardless as you say it's it's
let's see what's going to happen
but as I told you before the fans for me
always will be in my side will be always
in my heart I see during the days when I
go to the street to love the passion
that people have for me
um the respect
I hope that they never forget
the things that I will continue to do it
not only in the past but in the present
too Manchester will be always in my side
defense will be always in my side
doesn't matter what's going to happen
and I appreciate the loves that they
send for me all the time even when I'm
done play and we even when they when
they criticize me the always will be in
my heart so thank you to Dollar supports
hope to see you soon and uh they always
will be in my heart
and what about Ceramics the man who
persuaded you to come back again
really like a father figure to you
really in many ways like another another
father to you
what's his
take on everything that's been happening
what's his opinion of all this
I don't speak with him like one month
ago but it's always on my side you
always understand me he knows that he
knows better than nobody that the club
is not on the path that deserves to be
he knows everyone knows the people who
don't see that is because they don't
want to see they are blamed
the fans
they are always
the answer
and the passion for the game Manchester
belonged to defense but they should know
the truth the infrastructure they are
not good they should change if not
Manchester is not going to be where
there used to be what when Sarah Alex
Ferguson David Gill was and how to be
part if they count with me to help the
club
to be successful if not the life will
continue I will continue to to my
journey I will continue to make fans
happy and score goals and do it tricks
and everything and
um it's good it's part of my journey
up next Ronaldo and Lionel Messi and the
World Cup in Qatar
[Music]
I want to just talk to you briefly about
the World Cup
um your fifth World Cup and you say it's
your last but I mean you'd only be 41 at
the next one could we have a sixth World
Cup potentially will be tough
it'll be tough so this may be the last
one probably yes you've got an exciting
team full of experience and young
players Portugal are you optimistic
about your very optimistic we have a
fantastic coach we have a good
generation of football players
I'm looking forward that we're going to
do with Amazing World Cup would that be
for you the the Pinnacle of your creator
win a world cup with Portugal Please add
on I don't
I never well I dreamed one time about
that
holding the World Cup yes
it's gonna be tough extremely difficult
but everything is possible but
of course we're gonna compete it's hard
to beat who are the who are the biggest
Rivals we are not the favorites
no of course but who do you weren't
famous when you won the exactly exactly
who do you think are the ones to really
watch who are the best squads out there
probably France
France
I will put Spain Argentina Germany
Brazil Brazil of course they look good
today they look good what about you
haven't mentioned them ah England as
well yeah yeah of course England you
think England have a have a chance have
a chance beside Portugal in my opinion
uh
uh but let's see we'll be different
will be in a winter is it weird playing
at winter do you care do you care
don't really care to be honest a part of
the issue is that the country wherever
they try to
they try to speak now that it wasn't not
good option to do it there but they
should do that before we should focus
only in football the competition to
people to enjoy do you think all the
politics and the morality debates and
stuff should that all be left aside now
100 focus on the on the game I feel that
of course they should though they should
do that that debate should be had before
your award exactly exactly they should
concentrate it in in all competition all
the national teams the people to be
welcome in a in a in Qatar and I I see I
see a good tournament to be honest I
think Qatar they are prepared they are
prepared for that and we'll be where to
play in the beginning of the Season yes
but in the same way a challenge I think
it's to be honest it's good I feel good
I feel with good energy so what about
this idea you get to the final
Portugal the Argentina
you scored two Messi scores two
the last minute 94th minute
you score a third for your hat trick and
you win the World Cup is that be honest
too good is that the dream it's too good
I didn't expect that two good dreams but
if it happened
oh come on
you can scare you can score another
player I don't care I don't care if the
Portugal being a final in score even the
goalkeeper I will be the most happy man
in the world but if if this happened
come on
I will say I will finish football if
this happens
all right yeah
100
I mean it may well be Messi's last World
Cup he's never won it either I mean you
are you know you're linked forever the
pair of you to me the greatest there's
ever been
you're number one for me uh thank you
he's number two you're number one to you
he's number two
um but it's an amazing relationship you
have even though you're not I know great
friends or anything but you're always
respectful when you see each other what
do you think of him Messina as you both
head to maybe your last work as a
football player yeah and as a person
amazing player is Magic top
as a person we share the state
16 years imagine 16 years
we are the highest we share so I have
great relationship with him I'm not
friend of him in terms of what I mean
friend is the guy who is with you in
your house or speaking the phone no but
it's like a teammate he's a guy that I
really respect the way he always speak
about me
even his wife or my wife my girlfriend
they always respect and they're from
Argentina my girlfriend is from
Argentina so good what I'm gonna say
about Mexico great things he's a good
guy is you do everything for football
the best player you've ever seen
excluding yourself
probably yes
um
zidane probably
yes that I
play fight with him yes have you ever
had dinner together never would you like
to why not one day to sit down and
listen I I like it can I come I love of
course I love to meet people I love
people you know I like I love to share
things ideas learn things ideas new
histories New Brains why not
I will do it for sure I will do it that
would be in a few years yeah at the bats
as Maradona and Pele yes
no problem come on I'm a good person I
know I've I have a good heart and you
know I'm
I don't like I don't like to you know to
criticize people it's not the way I I
took my life everything is positive and
it's like a weird sequence of events and
papay goes to Real Madrid and PSG ring
you up and go we've had a great idea we
want to put Messi and Ronaldo everything
it's everything it's possible in in in
football so and that would be incredible
why not I don't know I don't know as I
told you before they sell some shirts
for sure for sure for sure they will
sell a lot of shirts we're also going to
win the Premier League I hope so you do
mind yourself first if not if not
Arsenal is some team that I like to see
to play did you write the team at the
moment yes I do I like the team I like
the coach I think they do it a good team
and uh if Manchester United don't win
the Premier League I will be happy if
Arsenal do or would you like your legacy
to be Christian I mean well let me ask
you first do you have any plans to
retire I mean how long do you think you
can keep playing football I want to play
two years more three years more two
three years my Maximo I want to play
with
want to finish with 40. I think will be
a 40 40.
a good age but I don't know I don't know
the future sometimes you plan you plan
one thing for your life and as I told
many times the life is the dynamic and
you never know what's going to happen
Tom Brady in America the great NFL
quarterback retired
then he has a conversation with you on
the Old Trafford pitch and whatever you
said to him I'm psychology so the next
day he comes out of retirement
psychology see I'm good psychologist
what did you say no I thought I thought
it took the decision a few weeks before
uh but it was good what did you talk
about you two guys speak about in
general is very very smart guy uh he
knows a lot about football we have a
nice conversation and he's called a hat
trick that does it yes I did he give me
good energy when I have good and good
energy and you have another goat in the
stadium because they're fire you up
exactly yeah that's a goat thing right
yes yes it's energies it's all about
energy when you are when we have good
energy around you
I can be interesting things
what about Jordan Peterson who I know
came to see you amazing man yeah because
I've interviewed him a few times and he
was fascinated to meet you and to talk
to you both about private things about
what had happened to your family this
year but also about professionally you
and your situation
I'm a huge fan of him I I read his book
12 rules
and I felt that is really really
interesting guy and I love to meet smart
people and uh fantastic man and I
learned a lot some advices that he gave
me
he gave you
with a nice strategic conversation not
only for the moment of my life I mean
not only for football because my life is
not resume only for football I have I'm
a businessman I've you know and many
important things on my life and when you
are surrounded with these people for
with you as well people that
make your life more interesting they
reach something in your daily life I
appreciate because
is that kind of people that thinking
outside the box which is I I appreciate
and we had a nice conversation strategic
conversation not only for the moment but
for the future as well he gave him some
points that I never expect but
the beginning was to meet him a good
person an intelligent person and uh was
fantastic and I we keep in touch I speak
with him it's good
you're going to do Cristiano Ronaldo's
12 rules to life why not for the future
maybe more rules exactly for the future
probably I wanna I wanna educate it I
want to educate it not only my family
but my fans as you know I have a lot
millions of fans probably for the future
I want to do it some book but not the
type of book I've got a good idea for
you on that yeah I told you it's a good
one but to help people how to be
how to maintain longevity and also I
think in your case how to survive life
right it's a lot of people out there who
are struggling to just deal with life
and the one thing you do better than
anybody I've seen in sport
is resilience
mental strength right that's what it's
really I think it's the most important
thing and I can see me in the future of
course I'm I want to improve my English
it's very good it's much better even
than last time I interviewed yeah but I
have to improve I have to do more
interviews I have to improve I know and
I'm I'm I I I want to improve
and I see myself to do it when I'm
retired to speak from
millions of people
advices
how to be a professional player how to
maintain your longevity how
I'm not psychologist but I passed
through many many things and I can you
know about this above all how to win how
to win which is the most important I
think it's what it's all about I have
experienced to
to expire people
for that I think I'm I'm a role model
and I I can help many many people in
that way if they want my help I want to
listen to it right for sure especially
the young people I want to be with the
young people to speak with them not only
for them but for the Fathers as well to
put him in a in the right spot
Cristiano what a pleasure thank you very
much indeed thank you very much bills
very pleasure for me thank you thank you
very much
Andy with a wink of course it did an
extraordinary interview with an
extraordinary footballer and an
extraordinary man can you change your
mind that's for you to decide one
thing's for sure he set the record
straight and he was most definitely
uncensored
foreign